I played in Boston
so many times.
The history speaks for itself.
But for this one time,
when I went to Boston
for this game six,
I felt absolutely nothing.
I don't think many people
would ever think about that game
when they would think
about my career.
But for me, that was the one.
When the pressure is higher,
when more is on the line,
it's even more important
that you perform.
Everything's just clicking.
You're winning. You know,
don't mess this up.
This perfect day now is just
turning into this nightmare.
Breaks down frame
by frame in my head.
It's like a camera.
If I make a mistake, bam!
This is where it happened.
I can tell you everything.
I had a full on breakdown,
'cause I realized
what was on the line now.
I started crying,
and then I had to go
out and compete.
That's when it dawns on me.
I don't care what happens.
Why not just go for it?
We did something that
I'm still trying to repeat today.
I was able to win
a championship that year.
That was the result
of feeling nothing.
You just do it.
You become it.
I can feel my momentum
picking up.
Ah, this looks good.
You're in rhythm with each other
like you have the same pulse.
They're calling you
the greatest athlete in the world.
You think about
this whole lifetime
all building
to this one moment...
I couldn't believe
it was happening.
I wish I can bottle nothing up.
I'll tell you that.